we are the court of owls and we require
more than words
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Batman Korda valas video just an
explainer for what they are from the
comics and how the TV show how Gotham is
doing them so just careful for spoilers
for things that have happened on Gotham
so far this season so when you talk
about the court of Alice most people are
talking about Scott Snyder's run on the
Batman comic book he was the guy that
came on at the start of the new 52 wrote
this amazing Batman run probably longer
than almost anybody wrote on any other
title during the new 52 up to present
day he just left the title so I think he
wrote about 50 it was either 51 or 52
issues total they just had his epilogue
they just changed Batman's costume so
scott Snyder's run on Batman was amazing
but a big part of that was introducing
the court of owls it was a new creation
of the new 52 it did not exist prior to
scott Snyder's run so there was a lot of
retconning of Gotham City's history it
was an attempt to create a mythology
around the ruling families of Gotham
going back to the beginning of the city
very stanley kubrick eyes wide shut
shadow organization controlling the
history of Gotham for centuries so what
the TV show is done is it just
introduced that via this mask here and
what it's calling the white haired woman
that's all she was referred to on IMDB
so we don't have a name for her yet but
there are people who are members of the
court the really wealthy people then you
have the talons which kind of looks like
fish Mooney's outfit here she almost
looks like she's wearing a version of
talent armor and she even has
fingernails that look a little bit like
talons but the talons are very literally
sleeper agents like people that have
been dead and brought back to life that
they keep on ice till they need them now
you see on the TV show on Gotham why the
court is funding Hugo strangers
experiments in bringing people back from
death they want a solution to cheat
death they also want to create talons so
it seems like the TV show is doing is
it's just teasing that now in the finale
and the season 2 finale and we'll push
deeper into the mythology of the court
of Alice in season 3 so does that mean
it's pretty cool I'm pretty happy the TV
show is doing it it seemed like they
were taking their time but now we
understand like they just wanted to
spend most of season 3 on that so they
had to build up to it through Hugo
Strange and that's how they're
explaining the death of Bruce's parents
they went against the court so the court
took action and got rid of Thomas Wayne
that is somewhat can into the comics so
even though they changed a lot on
TV show they changed a lot of names they
changed a lot of the way the characters
look they are doing comic-book things if
you want to read that original court of
owls run the storyline is actually
called night of the owls but I believe
they just collected Volume one of the
new 52 Batman run and just called it
court of owls so you can buy that too
you can buy the collected edition I
always get a lot of questions about
Bruce Wayne becoming Batman on the TV
show what I think might end up happening
is they'll go the Smallville route where
at the very end whatever season that
ends up being they'll tease the cow like
he'll put a version of it on in that BAM
it'll like slam to black just like Clark
on Smallville put the costume on in the
very final episode because DC is so
protective of the way Batman and
Superman are depicted I think they just
don't want to over saturate things
because they're in the process of
rebooting the movie universe right now
but David Mizzou's the person who
actually plays Bruce Wayne on the show
is about 15 years old now so in about
three years which would be season five
of the TV show
he'd be 18 right about the time Bruce
Wayne is close to Batman technically in
the comics he was about 25 when he first
took the mantle of the bat but you could
totally fudge that for the TV show a
little bit they kind of did the same
thing with the Smallville TV series they
just they played with the dates a little
bit so let me know in the comments what
do you think about them doing court of
owls in the TV show who do you think the
first Talon would actually be because
they would definitely do a talent if
they're doing court ivalice and do you
think that Warner Brothers will ever let
them do the cape and cowl on the TV show
even if it's in the very final episode I
think that would be a totally fair
compromise normally they don't let them
do movie things on the TV shows but I
think in a case like this where it's
just like a brief one-off thing where
it's like okay the show's going away so
we're gonna go out with a big black bat
I think it would totally work but what's
gonna happen tomorrow is there's a big
battle royale on the flash so be sure to
subscribe to get that video and I'll be
posting my Game of Thrones Q&A while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here to learn all about the
Harley Quinn spin-off movie it's gonna
be a Suicide Squad spin-off all-girl
team up and you can click here for my
Game of Thrones video from last night
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight